pleasure
Frederick Hess is author of the new book
common sense school reform next on book
TV he looks at the current state of
American education with authors Abigail
Fernstrom and Thomas talk this event
from the Brookings Institution in
Washington DC is an hour and a half good
afternoon we'll get started my name is
Tom Lovelace I want to welcome you to
Brookings in the brown center on
education policy today we're going to be
talking about a major new book on school
reform authored by Frederick M Hess Rick
Hess I'd like to introduce the panel
rick is going to speak first and then
Abigail thorne strim and tom talk will
offer some comments about the book at
that point then we will ask Rick if he
wants to take three or four minutes to
respond to their comments and then we'll
open it up to the floor for questions
when we get to the questions let me ask
you to wait until we get the microphone
to you c-span is filming today and we
want to be sure that your heard in terms
of your question let me now introduce
the panel first of all this will be in
reverse order of which they'll be
speaking Tom talk is writer in residence
of the National Center on education and
the economy in Washington DC and the
author most recently of high schools on
a human scale how small schools can
transform American education that's
published by beacon press tom was the
guest scholar here at Brookings from
1999 to 2002 he taught at the harvard
graduate school of education in 2001 and
between 1989 and 1999 tom was a writer
and editor at US News and World Report
where he covered education Abigail thern
stern is a senior fellow at the
Manhattan Institute in New York a member
of the Massachusetts State Board of
Education and a commissioner on the
United States Commission on civil rights
she received a PhD from the Department
of Government at Harvard University in
1975 Abby has authored several books and
journal articles with her husband
Harvard a story and Stephen thern strim
she recently co-authored no excuses
closing the racial gap in learning and
that book was named one with the best
books of 2003 by both the Los Angeles
time
in the American School Board Journal
finally our author today rick has
Frederick M house is a resident scholar
and director of Education Policy Studies
at the American Enterprise Institute and
executive editor of Education next he's
a former public high school social
studies teacher in Baton Rouge Louisiana
holds an m.ed in education and an MA and
PhD in government from Harvard
University prior to joining AEI Rick
served as professor of education and
politics at the University of Virginia
and as a senior fellow at the
progressive Policy Institute rick has
authored several books monographs and
journal articles his latest book which
we will hear about today is called
common sense school reform was published
by Paul great press with that please
join me in welcoming requests thanks
very much tom it's a pleasure to be with
all of you today um with that I'll get
started common sense school reform was
written an answer to a question the
question was posed by a good friend the
superintendent of a mid-sized school
district I've been giving him a hard
time about his school reform plan as I'm
want to do and finally he said so what
would you do if you were in my shoes and
being an academic I did what academics
are trained to do I waffle I said well
it's tough to say so he said uh huh come
on smart guy you know so much what would
you do so I did what academics really
want to do which was I told him and that
was the genesis of this book I told them
that America's schools are in a state of
crisis though it's not the one that we
usually imagine American schools are not
awful they are not gutting our economy
and they are not terribly unsafe on
balance given the population they serve
they are probably doing about as well as
they did two generations ago the real
crisis is that performance we deemed
adequate 50 years ago is neither
tolerable nor defensible today yet
demands for radical and appropriate
change are met
protestations of good intentions please
for patients in an endless stream of
ineffectual tinkering the dimensions of
the problem are straight forward
researchers have estimated that in 2001
just thirty two percent of all 18 year
olds graduated from high school with
basic literacy skills and having
completed the courses needed to attend
four-year college the 2003 National
Assessment of Educational Progress
reported that just thirty one percent of
fourth graders and thirty-two percent of
eighth graders were proficient in
reading these are not figures for poor
or for urban populations these are
national figures perhaps most
distressing our children lose ground
during their years in school well our
nine-year-old score above international
norms our thirteen-year-old slip below
average and our 17-year olds avoid the
bottom only by eking past nations like
South Africa Cyprus and Lithuania the
common culprit for our educational
travails is a lack of funding however by
any reasonable standard American schools
are exceptionally well funded in 2000
for instance the most recent year for
which international comparisons are
available the OECD reported the u.s.
spent significantly more per pupil than
any other industrial democracy even
those famous for the generosity of their
social programs for instance at the
primary level the u.s. spent sixty-six
percent more per pupil in Germany
fifty-six percent more per pupil in
France twenty-seven percent more per
pupil in Japan eighty percent more per
pupil in the UK and sixty-two percent
more than Belgium not only are we
spending education dollars without
getting a lot of bang for the buck but
we're actually spending more than we
think UCL a business professor bill
ouchy has calculated that in New York
City drawing 2001 02 so a couple of
years ago adding the cost of debt
service school construction and
renovation to the eleven thousand nine
hundred and change and reported current
expenditures meant at the district
actually spent more than 14 thousand
dollars per pupil in LA the true per
pupil
austin 0102 was over 13,000 dollars per
pupil yet in these districts more than
half of fourth graders failed to make
even basic proficiency on the nape
reading tests from 1996 through last
year the u.s. education spending grew by
more than fifty three percent from 287
billion to over four hundred and forty
billion this money has allowed schools
to avoid cutting fat or rethinking
organization even as other agencies and
organizations whether for-profit
nonprofit government agencies have
slimmed down in nineteen fifty schools
employed 19 teacher for every 2.4
teachers by 1999 the ratio was more than
twice that one non teacher for every 1.1
teachers almost a one-to-one ratio
nonetheless educational leaders
routinely explain that they don't get
the resources they need and therefore
cannot reasonably be held responsible
for helping all students to succeed in
Buffalo the superintendent of a district
spending well over eleven thousand
dollars per student told Education Week
last year I don't know how to make
services multiply with decreased
revenues I don't know how that's humanly
possible unless it's like the loaves and
the fishes in fact a quarter of the
nation superintendents told public
agenda last year that a lack of funding
means that quote only minimal progress
can be made in their schools the problem
the problem that policymakers and
education officials are loath to address
is a system of schooling seemingly
designed to frustrate competence
teachers are hired essentially for life
to rehab hazard recruiting processes
there is little systemic recognition for
excellence compensation and desirable
assignments are treated as rewards for
longevity in forming decisions with data
is considered novel a breakthrough
concept while the very words efficiency
and productivity are derided as alien to
the culture of public schooling the
result is a culture of incompetents in
which educators learning to keep their
heads down avoid causing waves and play
defense our schools look this way
because the structure actually once made
sense in a world where most students
went on to work in factories or other
blue-collar jobs it was enough if
schools kept children occupied and
educated the talented tenth when schools
had a captive teaching force of talented
women and African Americans it made
sense to limit entry to the profession
and build compensation security senior
to me compensation seniority and benefit
systems that encourage teachers to stay
put for their entire careers when it was
difficult to rapidly collect and analyze
solid information on student learning it
was reasonable to compensate educators
without regard to student performance
and to protect educators from capricious
treatment at the hands of administrators
the world has changed and that's the
bottom line a changing economy requires
that all students master skills once
needed only by an elite our assurance
that talented women and minority college
graduates would be forced to choose
teaching due to a lack of viable options
is long past schools compete for
increasingly mobile workers in a labor
market filled with tens of millions of
white-collar jobs that beckon to
potential teachers advances in
technology and testing have made
accountability and information available
in a manner unimaginable even 15 years
ago
confronting this reality there are two
paths to education reform what I call
status quo reform in common-sense reform
status quo reformers believed that the
nation's millions of teachers and
administrators are already doing all
they can and will willingly make hard
choices or seek new efficiencies if
these are only pointed out to them
consequently status quo reformers
presume the way to improve America's
schools is to provide more money
expertise training and support what we
in the profession often call
capacity-building common-sense reform me
status quo reformers embrace new
pedagogies smaller schools new
assessment strategies and any number of
widely held reforms however unwilling to
consider fundamental change in our
approach to schooling they allow the
status quo to define what is possible
status quo reformers dabble in
curricular and pedagogical reforms but
steer away from radical changes in job
security accountability compensation or
work conditions the only subset of
changes that status quo reformers tend
to embrace are those that would occur
outside of the schoolhouse now it's true
that there are many non-school changes
like better nutrition or more engaged
civic leadership that would improve
children's lives and boost their
academic success however the status quo
tendency to allow discussion of school
improvement to meander into these issues
makes it easy to dismiss education
problems we can address in favour of
questions that schools are ill equipped
to manage issues like economic and
racial inequality have a tremendous
impact on children's opportunities and
must be addressed but we should not
allow musings on public housing or
welfare reform to stand in for
tough-minded efforts to improve
schooling common sense reformers
recognize the merit of many status quo
suggestions many of these proposals are
reasonable and helpful
or at least for some kids and at least
in some locales however common sense
reformers believed that these efforts no
matter how pedagogical useful are
generally tangential to or distractions
from the larger task of rooting out the
culture of in competence common-sense
reform rests on two precepts
accountability and flexibility centuries
of experience tell us that people work
harder smarter and more efficiently when
they are rewarded for doing so that
people do their best work when goals are
clear and they know how they'll be
evaluated that's smart educated and
motivated people can find ways to do
better and that professionalism only
flourishes when professionals have the
flexibility to use their judgment and
their skills common-sense reform seeks
to construct a culture of competence in
schools a culture where success is
expected excellence is rewarded failure
is not tolerated and professionals are
accorded the respect they deserve absent
relentless pressure even the best
intentioned educator may shy away from
pursuing efficiencies when they require
dislocation or wrenching adjustments the
common sense reformer assumes that
educators for better or worse or a lot
like everybody else some educators are
passionately committed to their craft
highly-skilled it will be so regardless
of rewards or guidance but most like
most attorneys and journalists and
doctors and think tankers will be more
effective when held accountable for
performance when rewarded for excellence
and when given the opportunities to
devise new paths to success common-sense
reform is the foundation upon any number
of upon which any number of
instructional advances can comfortably
rest but without which systemic
excellence will continue to prove
illusory
now I know this is all a bit abstract so
let me get more concrete real education
reform rest on five pillars tough-minded
accountability competition workforce
reform leadership and reinvention test
based accountability and competition
provide the impetus to compel leaders to
make hard choices in pursuit of
excellence while the other measures
provide requisite flexibility
accountability forces managers and
leaders to rethink systems and practices
it relies upon tough-minded testing
systems and to market competition
working in tandem to compel educational
leaders to make hard choices it's not a
question of compelling managers or
employees to work harder it's not about
asking educators to work 60 hours a week
instead of 45 or 90 instead of 60 it's
about forcing managers and leaders to
rethink systems and practices let me use
a painfully familiar example for
simplicity's sake consider the Detroit
automakers who fell upon hard times in
the late 70s they had taken a producing
oversized and poorly designed cars had
gotten lazy about quality control had
permitted coughs and union contracts to
spiral out of hand and it added layer
upon layer of middle management you know
this story this is an old story guess
what they knew about these problems
these weren't a secret but no one seemed
able to do anything about them finally a
dramatic loss of market share rocked
shareholders who demanded energetic new
leadership and forced out those leaders
unwilling to comply under duress these
new leaders suddenly found it possible
to rethink their product line redesign
quality control / middle management and
renegotiate contracts while cutting
costs but had been thought impossible
five or ten years previously the
transformation was not about parading
workers but about requiring not
requesting but requiring those in charge
to bite the bullet and make painful
decisions and those below them to
accommodate those decisions flexibility
is
empowering professional educators to
more effectively serve their students
this requires rethinking how we hire
manage and compensate educators staff
schools select and compensate
educational leaders and use technology
all right let me talk about a few
specifics first we need accountability
systems that have real consequences for
individuals and which ensure that all
students master at least the gatekeeping
skills schools must focus on doing a few
crucial things and doing them well at a
minimum at an absolute minimum schools
must ensure that all children master the
gatekeeping skills of reading writing
mathematics and possess a fundamental
grasp of science and history of course
we want schools to do more a lot more
but this is the essential starting point
if schools aren't doing this they aren't
doing their job second that centralized
accountability needs to be complemented
with real competition I'm not talking
about small-scale voucher programs or
about charter efforts but about real
competition that provides opportunities
for diverse forms of excellence and that
implies real consequences for
educational leaders and their teams when
they fail to compete effectively school
choice programs do not necessarily imply
competition in fact they rarely do
Moscow shoppers for instance could
choose from scores of grocery stores in
the 1970s join the very height of
communist rain in the old Soviet Union
nonetheless I'm not familiar with many
economists even my colleagues the
American Enterprise Institute or
free-market champions at University of
Chicago who would suggest that the
muscovite grocery market sector was
competitive or had benefited from
competition how can that be it's because
competition is not about Choice
competition demands the customer
decisions matter directly for the
personal and professional fate of
producers and for their employees third
together test based accountability and
competition can moderate the
homogenizing tendency of centralized
testing while mitigating the knee
to trust blindly in perrette and parents
discretion to make good choices when
given a choice among schools of course
using these in tandem requires that
accountability emphasize the value that
schools are adding rather than the
absolute level that which students are
performing the NCLB style focus on level
of achievement rather than the rate of
student learning or growth has the
perverse effect of rewarding schools for
attracting high-performing students and
punishing them for seeking to serve or
attract low performers fourth school
systems need to relentlessly seek out
talented and entrepreneurial teachers
and leaders and must strive to nurture
these individuals this means stripping
away licensure barriers that deter
promising candidates from becoming
teachers or school leaders and moving
away for a one-size-fits-all notion of
the teachers role or if how we should
train induct and support teachers fifth
educators who excel at serving children
who contribute in substantial ways to
their schools or who take on the
toughest assignments in terms of school
or classroom must be appropriately
recognized and compensated this means
providing large and sustained benefits
both monetary and otherwise conversely
contractual relationships must be
modified so that ineffective educators
can be identified and readily remediated
or fired six pensions and benefits and
schooling were designed for lifelong
teachers in a different American economy
retirement and benefit plans should be
shifted to defined contribution plans in
which educators vest almost immediately
if not immediately making the profession
more welcoming to an educated and mobile
population this would facilitate
movement between teachers in charter
schools and traditional public schools
make it less problematic for teachers
who are relocating across district or
state lines and make the profession more
receptive to an increasingly mobile
educated population
finally school districts should promote
flexibility and accountability by using
technology to reinvent provision and
using data to inform decisions
throughout the organization not just the
central district level merely dumping
computers and technology into schools
won't do much to make schools more
effective or to help students learn
everywhere always at all times sustained
improvement result from technology when
technology is used to relieve people of
routine tasks freeing skilled employees
to focus on the areas where their skills
are critical and can add real value this
process reduces the number of necessary
employees enabling managers to pay
valuable employees more now the fact
that these principles are considered at
all controversial in education circles
which of course they are suggests i
believe just how far out of kilter our
schools really are when status quo
reformers character the measures I'm
discussing is entailing a business
approach they do a tremendous disservice
to students to educators and to
themselves there is nothing uniquely
businesslike about asking that
organization to be accountable flexible
or spend public money wisely these are
not business principles these are
sensible guidelines for motivating
adults and ensuring that they
competently perform their chosen work
the travesty is that these are regarded
as business principles because they are
more typically found in the private
sector while we've permitted our most
precious domestic institution our
nation's public schools to totter along
with little more than good intentions as
a guide common-sense reform is not an
attempt to import business thinking into
education rather it reflects the
recognition that we should approach our
children's education with this at least
the same degree of seriousness that we
currently reserved for the production of
breakfast cereal barbecue sauce and
designer jeans
some may point to merit pay proposals or
No Child Left Behind styled
accountability and suggest the
common-sense reform is ascendant in
truth most of these are half measures
born of a reluctance to unapologetically
embrace common-sense principles
policymakers rhetorically speak of using
test based accountability to harness
tough-minded incentives then settle for
vague distant collective sanctions that
have little impact on individual
educators efforts to compensate
educators based on their work yield
timid tepid pay adjustments or bonuses
pegged to criteria crafted by status quo
authorities it's important to understand
that the various common-sense reforms
will not work as intended in isolation
from one another individually they are
politically unpalatable and given to
misfiring it is easy for advocates to
promote one tack is the answer this is
particularly true of proponents of
school choice but the results are often
disappointing in the search for miracle
remedies distracts from the need to
promote broader common-sense reform
accountability without the diversity
provided by markets without competent
principals familiar with outcome based
management or absent the flexibility
that allows managers and educators to
reinvent service provision is a recipe
for small-minded micromanagement and for
frustration alternative teacher hiring
without meaningful accountability
without retooled district hiring
practices or absent efforts to
reallocate resources to support
induction and ongoing professional
training will yield uneven and often
disappointing results common-sense
reform is not a miracle cure I don't
suggest that for a moment it will not
solve all or even most of the day-to-day
problems that educators struggle with it
will not ensure that teachers are well
trained that curricula or sound or that
excellence is replicated what it can do
what it can do is make it far more
likely that these improvements will come
to pass
it can create the preconditions for
excellence common-sense reform is only a
beginning there are many necessary and
sophisticated measures to cultivate
instruction and management that need to
extend far beyond the basic building
blocks of common-sense reform management
and organization behavior scholars like
clay Christensen co-author of the
innovators solution or Jim Collins
co-author of good to great and built to
blaming author of good to great and
co-author built to last have Ellis
trated how great organizations forge a
culture of competence through creative
thinking dynamic leadership and careful
attention to practices not through some
mechanical carrot-and-stick strategy
they are of course entirely correct as I
said common-sense reform is only a
starting point however the problem is
that when today's education managers try
to adopt the advice of a Christensen or
a Collins and try to assemble the right
people or create space for innovation
they quickly get mired down by the
regulations and routines that constitute
the culture of incompetents visionary
leadership requires more requires a
certain basic tool box otherwise it
amounts to little more than high hopes
and good intentions whether we will
unflinchingly embrace common-sense
reform is I suggest the question of the
hour in a world as complex and as
diverse as ours it is easy for simple
truths to get lost simple truths like
responsibility merit an opportunity I'm
suggesting that real school reform
begins by resurfacing this truce thank
well this is a wonderful audience for
Rick and he deserves it I love the book
it's terrific it's much needed I've
obviously got a croaky voice
of course schools must be held
accountable and administrators need
flexibility autonomy authority to set
salaries and so forth Rick rightly
argues as well for school competition
and choice though I would place even
greater emphasis on choice than he does
for one thing I don't think there's any
accountability without choice without
the ability of parents to say thanks but
no thanks I'm leaving but an additional
in addition the schools that I came most
to admire in five years of combing this
country for excellent urban education
were all schools that families had
chosen they had to be for reasons I will
return to the points Rick just outlined
are ones in a compressed form that Steve
and I also made in no excuses but Rick
greatly enriched my understanding of
those arguments filling them out
beautifully by drawing most notably on
the literature of management and
organization it's a literature I did not
know and from which I learned much but
in no excuses the book that my husband
and I co-authored we make a further
argument that I also still stand by our
argument boils down to two
interconnected points first point well I
agree with Rick that public education in
general nurtures a culture of mediocrity
I mean who can disagree with that I
approached his book from the vantage
point of my preoccupation of recent
years namely the racial gap in academic
achievement particularly in large urban
systems dismal quality of
schooling in our central cities where
black and Hispanic kids are so heavily
concentrated is the problem that you
could keep all of us awake at night and
so the question became for me in reading
Rick's book will his proposals truly
level the educational playing field
today whites averaged about sixteen
percent in districts of school
populations 60,000 and above basically
the size of Boston and San Francisco
these overwhelmingly majority minority
systems should I think be our central
concern in part because of the are
overwhelming moral obligation to black
children black children especially given
the history of American apartheid and in
part because the fabric of American
society will end up in shreds if we
continue to have a racially identifiable
group of educational have-nots non-asian
minority children black and Latinos
blacks and Latinos whose prospects in
life are inevitably compromised by the
low level of their skills and knowledge
and while some of these urban districts
are doing better than others the Nate
trial district results urban district
results so low-income black and Hispanic
students doing much better for instance
in Houston and New York than in DC and
Los Angeles there is no big city school
system clearly on the road to
transforming kids lives and that brings
me to my second and more controversial
point Rick argues that once a structure
that harnesses self-interest reward
success and so forth is in place then in
his words this system should
get out of the way of practitioners
quote common-sense reform provides a
foundation upon which any number of
pedagogical and instructional approaches
can comfortably rest he writes I agree
with the importance of the building
blocks that make for the foundation he
describes I do not agree with his
agnosticism with respect to pedagogical
and instructional approaches he has much
more faith than I do in what those
practitioners are likely to come up with
and thus he's seemingly it's a little
hard to tell but seemingly uncritically
cites the work of deborah meier and ted
sizer although neither have ever
demonstrated impressive results with
central city kids in other words I see
the reforms he he advocates as
absolutely necessary but insufficient
some formulas for inner-city education
work much better than others I believe
it's a flat statement that rests on
nothing but my own observation scores on
state exams and a smidgen of evaluation
by social scientists the best inner
cities that I know have extended Rick's
common-sense point they have looked at
the school population they are educated
and ask themselves another common sense
question what do these particular
students need and in doing so they see
students who acquire an education that
reaches far beyond the rock bottom
academic basics that Rick is talking
about these schools have worked
backwards as it were looking at the kids
and creating an education in direct
response to their perceived needs they
have a very large aim that of
transforming the next generation so that
it looks quite
different from that of the parents
parents or parent of the children
they're working with and in this sense
they are in to social engineering
Harvard sociologist Orlando Patterson
has said quote the greatest problem now
facing African Americans is their
isolation from the tacit norms of the
dominant culture his statement is really
the academic version of Bill Cosby's
recent remarks in which he talked about
black parents who are not parenting who
are buying $500 sneakers and won't spend
two hundred dollars for hooked on
phonics and about kids who can't speak
english and who will be shut out of the
world of economic success the best of
inner-city schools that I know insists
that black kids whom and that of course
was whom the Cosby was talking about
that they learned to speak Standard
English these schools have a simple yes
a common-sense formula they have
terrific principles of the authority and
autonomy to manage their budget set
salary staff the schools with fabulous
teachers get rid of those who don't work
all qualities Rick rightly and system
but they also have greatly extended
instructional time with more hours in
the day longer weeks longer years
essential I think for kids who come into
kindergarten already so far behind they
do not tolerate low-level disorder trash
on the floors bathrooms that are pig
sties the usual public school scene
where behavioral standards are much too
low these terrific schools focus
relentlessly on the core academic
subjects insisting their students learn
the times table basic historical facts
spelling punctuation the rules of
grammar the meaning of often unfamiliar
words I am less agnostic than Rick is
about curriculum content but and here of
course is a core
point in the book my husband and I wrote
these schools also aim as I've already
indicated to transform the culture of
their students as that culture affects
academic achievement not in a broader
sense but as it affects academic
achievement in other words as part of
the schooling they offer they insist in
addition to speaking Standard English
that kids show up on time properly dress
that they shake hands when introduced
they sit up straight at their desks
chairs pulled in workbooks organized
that they listen to teachers with
respect treating their classmates with
equal civility that they never waste a
minute in which they could be learning
they that they don't even bother to
offer an excuse for unfinished work and
so forth I am not advocating not
advocating central office
micromanagement of a culture of every
urban school so that it conforms to the
model that I've suggested but the
seeming success of that model does
suggest an argument for school choice
that Rick does not make these schools
would not exist without charter laws
that allow the Entrepreneurship that
Rick advocates I would turn every urban
school into a charter school freeing
them up freeing them from the collective
bargaining agreements and other central
office constraints
and the schools i came to so admire
would not work if the students and the
teachers had not chosen to be there
schools need to be able to attract
teachers who believe in their mission it
is incredibly hard work to teach at
these schools and the schools must be
able to say to the students you don't
like it here you're not willing to
commit yourself to the long hours the
self-discipline the demanding standards
then leave we can open we as teachers
can open the doors of opportunity but
you have to choose to walk through them
Rick likes choice and competition
because it will allow a thousand flowers
to bloom I like it among other reasons
because it is the precondition for the
growing of one particular flower common
sense with respect to educating kids
normally isolated from the test at norms
of the dominant culture is an even
taller order than the one Rick describes
but it is as essential as basic math
skills most employers want people who
are literate but they look as well for
such personal qualities as a polite
manner appropriate dress good work
habits and the like these are skills
essential to climbing the ladder of
Economic Opportunity race is the ground
on which Americans and whites
particularly generally lose their
footing and panic unless that ground is
considered very safe Bill Cosby went
where most educators would not even
dream of going the edge schools are not
only offering the mind-numbing courses
as Rick says they are also offering
cultural junk that acts as a break on
effective education for kids who need it
most
most teachers and principals have been
educated to be terrified of correcting
spoken English and imposing in other
ways that are misleadingly cold white
middle-class values and white knowledge
they are not alone in their terror
they're picking up cues from the
American culture in general thus on top
of Rick's impossible dream I'm imposing
another a cultural mission in which the
racial zeitgeist changes at schools and
at ed schools and the need to pull black
kids especially into American society is
honestly confronted if we want No Child
Left Behind that will be essential Rick
ends his book on a can-do note although
I think he's much too optimistic in any
case Steve and I also worked very hard
in no excuses to keep hope alive but the
road ahead is really tough and the
obstacles may be insurmountable in the
foreseeable future thanks
it's nice to be here first a quick
disclosure I know Rick personally I've
spoken at the American Enterprise
Institute at his invitation he's written
a very nice note on the dust jacket of
my most recent book and he's invited me
to and take part in some research in the
fall it's likely to enrich me by several
hundred dollars my sense of reading the
book is that Rick asks the right
overarching question how do we improve
public education on a large scale how do
we significantly upgrade not just a few
hundred schools but in an entire
educational system that's that is the
challenge today after 20 years into this
school reform movement that was launched
in the early 80s with the publication of
a nation at risk by the Reagan
administration and other reports we
still haven't cracked that not yet but
that is the right question to ask and I
think that Rick endorses and I would
agree with that Venus a set of
structural changes that goes a long way
to create the conditions for large-scale
change again and I think Rick was very
appropriately at the end of his remarks
said that that his agenda is necessary
but insufficient I would agree with that
analysis but his call for example for
more transparency and school performance
performance-based rewards and sanctions
for schools and individual educators
more school autonomy and staffing and
budgeting changes in teacher licensing
and administrator licensing that bring
about their that bring more talented
people into schools changes to choice
plans that strengthen the competitive
pressures on education
these are not new proposals their sound
ones though my sense is that Rick makes
an important contribution to our
understanding of how best to deploy such
reforms when he points out instances
where the promise of the reforms has
been lost in their implementation for
example there have been a number of
statewide choice systems and charter
school laws that ostensibly promote
competition but then include provisions
that in effect reimburse schools that
have lost students for the revenue that
they would have received if those
students were still in the district thus
as Rick argues and I would agree greatly
diminishing the the value of these
reform measures as levers of change as
as catalyst for the existing districts
where the kids came from to improve
themselves in order to maintain strong
and healthy programs that's just one of
many examples that the rick points to in
the book that i think we all are well
served by by understanding one way to
expand Rick's what and I should say that
that points out a very important thing
in school reform the devil is in the
details there's an awful lot of rhetoric
back and forth about structural change
about about conceptual change but it
really what really matters once you
agree on a set of overarching principles
to guide your reform efforts is how
specifically you implement them because
as Rick points out frequently in the
book you these well intentioned ideas
can come to naught if they're not
implemented appropriately or in the
right way
one way to expand Rick system of choice
would be to create publicly accountable
private school voucher programs that's a
little bit different than what we've
been hearing I think for the most part
about voucher programs when I publicly
accountable to my mind means that you
make sure that students and their
parents are selecting schools rather
than the other way around and that you
make sure that voucher schools meet the
same standards of transparency that that
we expect these days of public schools
and then you let the money follow child
to whatever qualified school that they
choose with extra money given to
disadvantaged and disabled students sent
to English language learners I actually
find it ironic a little bit troubling
that private school voucher advocates
don't demand the private schools release
test scores and other information as a
prerequisite for participating in
voucher programs inform consumers after
all are the are the basis of an
efficient market system or at least
that's what Adam Smith tells us another
way to make a choice more effective
would be to create mandes mandatory
public school choice programs and here I
find myself standing shoulder to
shoulder with a bee in her call for
universal charter programs in school
districts my sense is that most existing
choice programs are weakened by the fact
that they are dependent upon parents
choosing to choose where to send their
child you'll have a more vibrant choice
system if every student is required to
choose their schools as district 4 News
Harlem began doing two decades ago it's
a way to increase the intensity of the
market forces in a choice plan obviously
this wouldn't work in in rural Montana
or rural South Dakota where you don't
have as much you don't have a sufficient
density of students but in urban centers
you could require everybody to choose
their school even if they even if they
chose to go to their neighborhood school
and this and
by putting everybody in motion this way
you would have a much more vibrant
choice environment than we have now
where again we rely on parents and
students to choose to choose the school
that they're going to attend I think
it's also worth pointing it out that
it's possible to come away from Rick's
book thinking schools could be improved
simply by applying enough pressure on
them via rewards and sanctions or via
competitive pressures for students some
would say that Rick's Rick's is a
behaviorist model for school reform as
Canarian model I don't think that would
be fair to Rick it is certainly the case
the motivating students teachers and
administrators alike also entails
finding ways to ensure that they are
invested in their schools that they are
connected that they subscribe in the
broad sense to their school's mission I
sense that Rick's Rick believes this
though he doesn't say so explicitly in
the book I wish he had Rick but Rick
does endorse reforms that go a long way
to creating the sorts of connectedness
among students and teachers that is so
important to successful schools giving
students and teachers the opportunity to
choose the schools that they will attend
and giving individual schools more
autonomy over staffing over budgets and
even over curricular decisions
instructional decisions it's also
another point to make is that Rick's
advocacy of accountability systems
raises a very big question one that
again shows that the devil is in the
detail in these in the reform
conversation and one that is playing out
in the implementation of the No Child
Left Behind Act and that and that
question is how do a Juke aters create
large-scale accountability systems
without driving down standards for many
students because they are very much
political exercise is the setting of
standards in public education has to be
done so that not too many
students and schools would unquote fail
achieve ink as many of you read in the
newspapers a day pointed out that in
their study of half a dozen states
graduation examinations that in most
cases kids are being asked to do
material that that in other countries
junior high school students our middle
school students would be expected to
learn I mean that's one example and
another is that is that NCLB is is
causing many states to lower their
standards for two-thirds I would argue
of the nation's students as a result
NCLB is more harmful than helpful that's
problematic and so that so a very big
question is how do we solve this problem
and that may be a good point to end in
and ask Rick dancer thank you okay well
have Rick give a short response to the
two discusses first I'd like to thank
both Abby and Tom for taking the time
out today and joining us some felt the
comments were wonderful and entirely
appropriate I hope that I have enough
humility to understand the extent of my
contribution and common center for
common sense school reform is a limited
contribution I think it lays out and
clarifies things that we often get wrong
but as I tried to say my earlier remarks
um in no way do I want to suggest that
these simple changes these complicated
changes alone that I'm discussing are
going to make sure that our schools are
serving the children they need to I
think Abby and Tom raised two really
important sets of issues first Abby
touched it touched on the larger
question of questions of school culture
and curriculum and actual school level
behaviors and obviously these are
critical um I mean I think that's
inevitable and at the end of the day
that's what schools are about good
schools are about schools that teach
kids well and what teaching kids well
means means is it means partly it's
about modeling effective behaviors
partly it's about shaping them into the
kinds of responsible mature young
citizens we want them to become partly
it's about delivering an effective
content until Umi effective content and
partly it's about effective pedagogy and
instructional methods that's all given
on and Abby's right I'm actually more
agnostic than she is this is one of the
points where you know what where I think
there are a couple competing schools of
thought and at the end of the day I'm a
performance-driven guy my take is that
any school which is able to produce
reasonable and appropriate growth on the
part of students um is doing ok mi eyes
and like I said the only schools I want
to central are the only way I want to
centrally regulate schools are on the
gatekeeping skills I think as you try to
extend up and beyond that in terms of
accountability systems the way you I end
up doing is becoming
too prescriptive and too bureaucratic
and your dictates from the top down
seems to me that any school that is not
helping students grow you know at least
a moderate amount year to year in terms
of you keep me skills is failing at its
work and I'll not be available for folks
to choose I'll not exist I'll not exist
as a school entity any school that is
doing those things I'm then comfortable
folks having the having the opportunity
to select oh now that is not to suggest
for a moment that all schools are going
to be equally effective at delivering
that content and I think there's
probably you know a relatively broad
gray area where Abby and I meet my take
is that rather than try to prescribe
what effective pedagogy or content or
school models look like whether it's
kippur yes or anybody else is I would
prefer to have the results tell the tale
and what the market do its work and Abby
is suggesting that that is you know I
think it's suggesting that that's
unnecessarily messy and she's not
entirely sure that folks will have
either the capacity or the skill to
deliver this at a school by school basis
and so there's more room for
prescription and you know I think
there's reasonable I think there's a
reasonable room for conversation in that
area on Tom's point I think about the
dangers of account about the dangers of
accountability is precisely right I
think that's you know I think No Child
Left Behind style accountability level
of achievement is just I think massively
problematic on a number of grounds one
of which as I talked the way it
interacts with choice of course is it
wants a Peruvian schools to get try to
push out the door students who come into
low level of achievement which is but a
second of course is inevitably anybody
who you know Don Hirsch is a good friend
and he an essay just recently arguing
that you actually don't get homogenize a
shin through no style no child behind
Sal accountability I think that you know
the fact is away accountability systems
work is they build floors in the way you
build floors to any central act of
regulation is by shifting energy and
focus to making sure people are
mastering a basic love it's the way it's
supposed to work and so it's inevitable
that you're going to see a truncation at
the top and you're going to see a shift
in effort I'm a proponent of
accountability but I think those of us
who are supporters of
space accountabilities to be honest
about this the way that you avoid this
kind of a modernization or dumbing down
effect is I believe the only effective
tool at the end of the day is
competition in which families are able
to choose schools which are at least
attending to the basics which are
appropriate for their child and that
frees up schools to deliver a niche
services in terms of the kinds of high
schools that Thomas profiled in his work
in terms of meeting special needs
whether we're talking about English
language learners about particular
content interests about what not and at
the end of the day I think though that's
why it's so imperative that we not think
about choice or accountability as the
answer but we think about a sensible by
play in which we centralize testing to
ensure that schools are doing a
reasonable job of making sure students
are getting elise the things they need
to get so they're ready to be citizens
when they're 18 but at the same time
that we recognize that when we ask all
schools to do everything when we create
the shopping mall school we wind up with
schools that don't do anything
particularly well and that they don't
have a culture in which either teachers
or students are actually committed or
actually invested and so I think a lot
of it is about as we move into this next
stage um kind of 20 years plus a
traditional risk is thinking about the
interplay of using choice and
accountability Thanks okay let's go to
your questions and comments there we
have a lot of issues on the table who
would like to go first yes sir yeah hang
on just a second Toby get the mic to
thank you thank you I would just like to
find out the panel's opinion as far as
school vouchers are concerned because to
me I think it's not others rightfully so
I think it's also a form of reverse
racism because it takes away that higher
performing students and sticks them into
to a Catholic school per se so I just
wanted to find out your opinion if that
is is a necessary benefit so to speak
well my response is that as long as as
voucher schools that is schools that
receive voucher students are not allowed
as i said to select the students but
rather the students are allowed to
select the school then it's okay because
then you're on the screaming effect but
a lot of voucher I've gets don't support
that certainly a lot of voucher schools
potential voucher schools wouldn't stand
for that because they they're private
because it in part because they want to
select their students so I think it is a
you raise an important issue and my view
is that if if the voucher advocates are
willing to come halfway then I'll meet
him there otherwise I'm with you about
your advocate and I'm not sure why you
think that they would necessarily cream
for exactly the reasons Tom said I I
agree with the constraints that he would
place on vouchers and I also agree that
they have to be transparent in terms of
their own results and and indeed they
shouldn't qualify as about your school
unless they are serving the kids well
but I also have one additional thought
on on that question every child in let's
say DC the DC public school system which
has not been doing well to say the least
with its school population every child
to whom we give a better education we
are one child ahead and you know at the
end of the day that's a good thing ah
every every person that we rescue with a
new medicine who every person with a
disease that we rescue with a new
medicine where one person ahead even if
we can't rescue every pitch person every
single individual with that disease so
I'm into rescuing kids if necessary one
at a time five at a time ten at a time
whatever but in districts like DC we're
in bad shape we've
magic sure no I'm fine Mathias I'm found
the Fowler's so long as money actually
follows a kid which means I I'm
concerned most voucher programs are too
nice for instance Milwaukee in 99 as
soon as the pro voucher school board
took office first thing they did was I
went to madison wisconsin and lobbied to
ensure that most of the money which is
going to fund the milwaukee parental
choice program did not actually come any
longer out of milwaukee public schools
but came out of a new school district
kind of fictional district traitement
Wisconsin I'm concerned that the way
that you again that the issue is never
that educators don't want to serve kids
I you know I've been in a lot of plebs
it seemed very educated in suppose
teachers what have you who didn't want
to help that's not the question people
that you know people at Ford and GM the
70s wanted to build good cars question
is at what point do barrier seemed
insuperable and I've met a lot of
educators who say you know you know it
would wouldn't it be neat if but it's
just not reasonable given the way
business is done in the district and the
purpose of competition the purpose of
accountability is not to make teachers
and administrators start to want to
serve kids it's to create this
relentless pressure that no matter how
painful or dislocating the changes are
it's easier than not making the change
so it did the concern about
stratification segregate and potential
segregation and school and that you
raise I think the evidence actually
points the other direction I you know we
can argue about the social science here
but my rating the evidence is it
generally the people who want to utilize
choice for people who are worse serves
that the schools are in on so you don't
see the tendency that you suggest arm
but at the end of the day I think that
kind of competition created by charters
or vouchers that have real money
following the kids and creating real
pain at the schools they leave is a key
piece to both driving change and
avoiding the kind of homogenous ation
that Tom warned about one sense them I
really agree with that and by the way
about laws that allow public schools to
retain a great significance of the
per-pupil money for the students who
leave also also pertains to our schools
we're having a big fight in
Massachusetts about the funding of the
charter school law and whether the
public school should actually lose money
and how much when a child leaves the
district regular district school for a
charter school on charter schools of
course or public schools I mean it is a
remarkable fight we're still paying pub
regular public schools for the kids who
have gone to charter schools even though
the charter schools are still in the
public school system another question
yes here in front hi I'm starting
college in the fall where I plan to
major in elementary education so as a
prospective teacher um I just wanted to
know if you could tell me some of the
challenges I should expect in the next
five to ten years and how you recommend
I face them sheesh big question I don't
know finding a job in what sense do you
mean and the challenges in terms of
maybe new policies that are have are you
hope to be in the correlated to the
common sense school reform that you hope
to be enacted I'm a horrible
prognosticator actually Tom Abby um I
mean I think your biggest challenge is
going to be managing to get through
pedagogy courses that are required for
licensure Oh try to hit this Michael
sorry about that um I can't you about
that extends from there to there
no there's a challenge there's a
challenge anyway I had said I think you
your biggest challenge is gonna be to
get through the education that is
required to be licensed as a teacher it
is a mind-numbing and unnecessarily so
and you know even elementary school
teachers I I think both these gentlemen
would agree with us even elementary
school teachers really have to know math
I have to know the structure of numbers
they have to understand it they have to
have at least a I think they should have
an understanding of map through calculus
um I go into classes on in schools a lot
i go into classes all the time where
elementary school teachers they'll mean
they'll tell you you know math is not
their specialty and because their
elementary school teachers but they
think a fraction is hieroglyphics they
do not understand anything about math
and i loved-ed trust Katie hecox
organization I think it gives yes
invaluable information but one of the
things I think it does wrong is it
counts as people who have majored in
math people who have actually got math
ed courses under their belt that is
pedagogy that doesn't count as math
training in my view so you know I think
the biggest challenge you're going to
immediately face is getting a proper
education that will really enable you to
go into a classroom with the skills you
need to teach kids I would say just
briefly that that you will discover that
the nature of your relationship with
school administrators and with your
peers depending on where your teach will
be largely defined by a union contract
and I think that will be a challenge for
you to potentially a challenge for you
to come to terms with
let me just as moderator let me ask
something since I taught elementary
school for nine years and still at my
credential I think the number one
probably going to face is classroom
management and dealing with parents and
you will not be trained on how to do
that and that's very tough to figure out
you basically have to learn it on the
fly well that's hard to do yeah if
you're lucky you'll find a principal in
the school who will have some idea of
how to train uh you in the base in basic
classroom management but that shouldn't
be it shouldn't be assumed you need to
look for a school in which that occurs
right and and the real power the teacher
unions have with teachers is that they
protect teachers from administrators who
are going to blow them out of the water
any time a parent complains about
something yes in the back yes I have two
questions and maybe the first one you
can't cover in two minutes why our
public schools so bad when we're
spending so much on them I lived in
Europe for 10 years the teachers are
better paid it's just stunning for me to
hear that we're spending so much more
than European countries and getting so
much less and I don't think it's because
our teachers are overpaid and then
secondly for Abby as a proponent of
charter schools and I'm a mom in the
district who just chose a charter school
for my kindergarten age children are you
not worried about mediocre charter
schools especially in the district where
our alternate our alternatives are so
bad are we just going to keep them alive
and keep using our children as guinea
pigs at these charter schools until we
get it right there are there are good
charter schools but there are so many
bad ones well I'll take the charter
school question and I want Rick to take
Sofia historical one because I think it
is an historical one yr our schools so
bad when did they start to fall apart
and it severe it's a very very
interesting question um of course there
are lots of mediocre charter schools
charter schools be the Charter School
laws if they are good laws and not all
charter school laws are good law
there are huge differences between them
but if they're good laws all they do is
offer opportunity they do not guarantee
results but the good thing about charter
schools in the states in which they work
properly is if they don't deliver
results they're closed we have closed in
Massachusetts we've closed a total of
one charter school I would close more I
mean I'm on the State Board of Education
I you know if I had my druthers I'd
close more um the one that we closed was
simply dreadful I went and spent a whole
day there I know it was dreadful um the
problem with closing charter schools in
a lot of states or at least it's only
true in Massachusetts is that the
resistance to opening new charter
schools is so enormous the anti Charter
movement is so enormous that people are
reluctant to close the ones that are up
and running but again they provide
opportunity they don't guarantee results
and important they provide opportunity
but if the teachers are out under from
Vermont out from under the collective
bargaining agreements yeah I'm actually
learning interesting things if you look
at charter closures you'll find that
we've actually done not not unreasonably
at closing down charters for gross
malfeasance across the country on
financial propriety and appropriate
behavior it's not hard to get these shut
down because it's embarrassing it's a
public outrage what stuff to do only a
tiny sliver of charters have been shut
down for academic underperformance the
trick here is that the folks who are in
this school like it they think it's
better than the alternative and nobody
else really cares and so when a public
entity is asked to shutter the school it
so it plays out a lot like the fights
over sugar subsidies you know it's tough
to do we close the school at the parents
looked but we didn't and so I mean so
there these are certain issues and this
is actually one reason why at the end of
the day I think using competition is a
real enforcer of
the in compliment with you know gates
keeping keeping test based assessment of
charters is much more effective in terms
of steering them than 0 then
over-reliance on regulatory authorities
it's just really difficult for
regulators to monitor and shut down the
historic question is a need one I mean
right it's a great question how can we
spend a lot of money and still be
frustrated by what we're getting um
there's a lot of different answer people
can certainly give you a number of
different hypotheses what what I would
suggest is that the fundamental problem
is that schools are too corporate the
problem is the corporate model and
schooling was designed in the kind of
the 1892 1920 period it was a period of
revolution and American organizations
throughout the country on the model was
this idea called scientific management
we promoted particular by frederick
taylor also known as taylorism the idea
was that efficiently run organizations
should have a couple of experts the top
should figure out what everybody's
supposed to do and then you tell folks
how to do it and particularly in a
feminized profession like teaching the
folks in the classrooms doing it
particularly k 28 or women we were going
to have experts at the superintendence
of principals who were men and at those
places it had nine to twelve
high-schools particularly urban areas
you had a high incidence of men in those
classrooms and what we're going to have
was very hierarchical directive model of
how you ran a school we were going to
the scientists at the center we're going
to figure out how many kids should be in
a classroom they were going to figure
out how do you assign desks what
constituted a good curriculum and we
were going to then staff and run schools
in a court of this model at the time it
actually worked reasonably well this was
the model that helped make America into
a perhaps the world's most productive
participation in that period after World
War two when we were clearly the world's
leading a leading producer what happened
was we went through a revolution in
organization management we realized that
scientific management may have made
sense upon a time but that as technology
changes you had a much more educated
workforce the way to recruit
talent the way to utilize people skills
was not this model that had grown up in
the first half the night of the 20th
century but a model that was much more
flexible that focused on results and
then gave people leeway to do it and
what happened in the second half the
20th century from trucking to Airlines
to telecom to banking we had two
gingerly feel our way through taking out
this once appropriate model and there
are a lot of risks that are attendant
and we've seen some of them in terms of
stuff like enron tyco and nothing and
you often have adjustment periods when
we have to make sure that we do these
things correctly but what's happened is
we ultimately have a model which is very
very cost efficient for instance for
1972 2000 the number of what we in 1970
we had a teacher for every threat 23
pupils roughly by night by 2000 we had a
teacher for every 14.9 pupils at the
same time in 1970 a typical teacher
spent 4.5 hours of contact with students
a day by 2000 was 3.9 hours so we've got
is we've got more teachers they're
spending less time with kids we're also
spending on technology about a hundred
bucks a kid the last couple years and
per pupil so what you're doing is you're
spent you've got more people doing less
direct contact and spending on
technology that's a recipe for not
getting the most bang for the buck and I
think that's nobody's fault it's because
we're still using a set of institutions
which were once reasonable but it's time
that we really think about overhauling
them respond to both questions just
briefly I think charter advocates have
been a little bit short-sighted in not
pushing for tougher accountability
provisions because the relatively large
number of of failing charters invariably
end up on covered on the front page of
newspapers which has really hurt the
movement dramatically it's been
unfortunate but and and what you see now
within the Charter movement is a pretty
intense battle between sort of
libertarian force advocates on the one
hand those who who believe that charter
schools should exist in large part just
to be outside the public system beyond
the reach of public school authorities
that that is institutions that parents
control to a large extent and the more
pragmatic advocates of chartres on the
other hand checker fin being probably
the most prominent example who have come
around to the belief that in fact unless
charter schools do hold themselves to
high standards unless they do keep the
bargain which was the original premise
of charter schools ie stricter
accountability in exchange for less
bureaucracy then the movement could
could be in danger on the historical
piece I I guess I don't completely agree
with the premise that public schools are
sort of worse than they've ever been
today and that they in fact have started
to fall apart what I would suggest
instead is that we and Rick said this in
his comment his initial comments is that
we've never expected more of our schools
today that in then that we've never
expected as much of our schools as we do
today in nineteen fifty fifty percent of
white students and twenty five percent
of african-american students stayed in
school long enough to get a high school
diploma because high school diplomas
were more or less unnecessary from for
middle cut to achieve middle-class
status in America that has changed with
the evolution of the nature of work in
this country and so therefore that
combined with the civil rights movement
which sensitized us to large segments of
our population that in the past we more
or less neglected or wrote off has
created a very different set of
expectations for our public schools than
we had before and much of this movement
started by the way in the late 70s and
early 80s with the publication of a
nation at risk the premise of those
reports was that in fact the nature of
work was changing and we had to redefine
the mission of our schools accordingly
so I would argue instead that that our
schools are probably never been better
on average but that as Rick noted that
that's not nearly good enough today so
we're faced with an unprecedented
challenge in this country to expect much
more of all of our students than we have
ever contemplated we are expecting today
the vast majority of students to use
their minds well when passed we expected
most kids to use their hands and not
their heads after they graduated from
high school so that's a different
slightly different way of looking at it
it doesn't diminish the importance of
school reform or the enormity of the
challenge but it frames it slightly
differently second question since I
didn't answer it before I'm actually in
disagreement with both these gentlemen
on this I walk into schools and I ask
myself who's running this school the
adults are the kids and the answer is
very clear it's the kids who are running
them and I traced this right back to the
1960s and to cultural change in this
country I wouldn't disagree that that's
an important illness right here on the
Isle thanks this is I guess a question
for any of the panelists as an
educational forum practitioner Rick I
read the list of six or seven
recommendations and smile very broadly
and save my gosh if half these were in
place our work would be a heck of a lot
easier my next thought is if the force
that's supposed to bring about these
changes is largely through competition
and we've had at least with charters
well good I see you shaking your head so
I'll reform my question a little bit is
the force that's supposed to bring these
about competition and you will this
happen not what is it and you will it
happen in our lifetime violating your
you know your de mural against
prognostications sure uh-uh-uh craftily
sidestep the prognostication but no I I
think it's naive to suggest the
competition will bring these about I
mean partly because you know if you had
said to Michael Dell in the mid-80s we
want you to drive a revolution and the
purchasing delivery of personal
computers but we're not going to allow
you to decide how much to pay your
employees who to hire or who to fire
you're not going to see a so right it's
no it's naive to imagine that somehow
charters of our church without broader
set of changes are going to be able to
create healthy and constructive
competition on the charge and
common-sense reform is really to those
folks and I think I think there's
widespread recognition that we need to
do a lot better and folks aren't sure
how to do better so we why ended up
having a lot of energy to a lot of
different directions people know we need
to do right by our kids and they think
oh we can spend more and I'm not adverse
to more money in education I mean you
know I think all of us involved but I
think it's naive to suggest that that's
going to get us where we need to be um
there's a lot of folks a lot of
corporate new corporations particularly
do good heart and philanthropy they
support status quo efforts um there's a
lot of useful and a youthful reform
efforts going on in terms accountability
alternative certification or choice but
I think the problem is ultimately a lot
of folks mistake tactics for strategy
and strategy for a sense of kind of how
to reform schooling the problem is not
the way that we hire teachers the
problem is not a lack of choice the what
the problem is is it's that we have a
fundamentally coherent approach to
education that once made sense it
doesn't make a lot of sense given the
challenges and opportunities of our time
and so the key here is one to redirect
good-hearted efforts by a bunch of folks
who care whether that civil rights
community whether it's parent groups
whether that's corporate you know
corporal it for corporate philanthropies
or corporations invest in supporting
schools and help them understand that if
we're actually going to think coherently
about doing this it's important not to
promote one strand one tactic as the
answer or to simply try to refine
curriculum or support a couple of
classrooms and schools that are run
dysfunctional e but to fundamentally
take to the you know take a good hard
fresh look at how we're running the
system which means ultimately what we're
talking about is a clarifying exercise
ultimately what has to happen to school
boards and state legislatures have to
decide that they're willing to stand up
and change the statutes and change the
collective bargaining agreements that
structure the way we approach education
in this country and it's
not something they're inclined to do
it's something they're only going to do
if they sense that it's what their
voters if they what their constituents
want them to do so ultimately this
conversation has to be about making
parents and voters comfortable with the
with the notion that the right way we're
running our schools doesn't make a lot
of sense and that there's a much more
sensible practical common-sense approach
and that's going to be the starting
point for usable useful change is that
going to happen in the next five years
or 20 years I have no idea listen we
have time for one more question hi i'm
anna neagle from education leaders
council and this is kind of going back
to tom's comment about classroom
management most teachers that I know
friends and family members they like the
ideas of accountability and standards
and such and but they find that they're
somewhat impractical because they have
such problems with with classroom
management and they're having such a
difficult time getting a handle on that
and so my question is well I have to the
first is for Rick how does classroom
management find its place in
accountability and flexibility and for
Abby in the schools that you've seen in
urban districts especially how have they
overcome the classroom management issue
to get to the point where they can
achieve these standards and and such
yeah that's a great question um it's
very similar to the question when we
talk about state accountability systems
and you say you know teachers already
teaching the best they can if the kids
aren't mastering their terial how do you
you know and that's right I mean it you
know it's the critics are right when
they suggest that imposing
accountability does not magically
improve the pedagogy or instruction or
classroom management skills of educators
that's of course not what it's supposed
to do what it does is it creates
expectations and creates pressures now
how are you supposed if teachers right
now aren't able to control their
classrooms how are they supposed to do
with the day after accountability or
features aren't bringing their kids to
where they need to be in terms of
literacy how are they going to F well
the point is it's it's foolish to expect
these teachers are somehow going to
magically
come more effective that's not how
accountability ever works what needs to
happen is these organizations the folks
in charge of the organization's the onus
is on them what can you do for instance
right now it's dreadfully difficult if
you're a principal of a school to do the
kinds of things abby was talking about
in terms of maintaining order why
because if you suspend a student or if
you deal harshly with a student who
deserves it you will get a lot of flat
from those parents you're likely at
particularly at the middle class you're
likely to hear for an attorney if they
can afford one a foul problem is that by
kind of smoothing over those waters or
by knuckling under what you do is you
create it's kind of the broken windows
phenomenon the JQ Wilson spoke about
decades ago so you end up is creating a
culture in which it's hard for anybody
to draw the line with students um so
part of this and similarly those
principles feel that they're in a
difficult position because they know
that their superintendent in the central
ministration will often be hesitant to
back them up central districts hate that
have these problems turn ugly and
attract media attention and they would
much rather just have it go away so much
of what we're talking about in terms of
accountability in terms of competition
is changing the incentive structure
under which superintendents and their
staffs and principals operate to change
the Maloo on which teachers are expected
to do their work similarly if right now
if we're spending you know if we're
spending professional development
budgets in ways that don't have a clear
outcome in terms of student performance
or classroom management well that's a
problem but what you tend to have the
constellation of forces between teacher
preferences semi-autonomous curricular
development operations in the central in
the district a collective bargain so you
have is a whole bunch of reasons if the
money doesn't get spent on activities
which are necessarily linked to
constructed outcomes in terms of teacher
behaviors or teacher effectiveness and
which nobody everybody says well it
would be neat to do it differently but
it's not feasible and again the point
about accountability is to create the
necessities to no matter how unpleasant
folks do it now the flip side of that is
they've got to have the tools if a
principal is ultimately unable to do
anything in terms of student management
in terms of teacher reassignment I don't
care how much pressure you put on them
all you're going to do is make their
life unlivable and crit
so correct there which is why we always
think in terms of the balance so what
accountability what competition do is it
create the pressure to do the things
which have previously been unimaginable
but to make that effective you've got to
give these teachers administrators the
tools to do it or you are being
unreasonable and what you ask of them
yeah it's not only you're going to get a
lot of flack if you deal with the
disruptive kid but if the kid happens to
be protected by I DEA and his disruption
has been labeled a disability then you
cannot move that student out of the
classroom or are ultimately out of the
school without a parent's consent and
you know principles I mean as Rick
stated the the process of dealing with
disruptive kids is so overwhelming
principles are all the incentives are
running in the wrong direction
principles just send the kids back to
the classroom but there is it seems to
be a larger question buried in what you
say and and that is I mean I think
classroom management can be taught and
by the way well-managed classes can be
very large and some of my favorite
schools class size runs about 40 to 45
kids they have the money is used for
other purposes but you have touched it
seems to me on a larger problem that is
buried in Rick's book and and it's not
fully dealt with what he has a lovely
little statistic that that two percent
of the american workforce our classroom
teachers well you know if that if that's
true and of course it is true um there
is a limit to how many academically
highly skilled what we would call high
quality people we're going to have in
American schools so we need to find a
way of dealing with academically average
college graduates or below average we're
going to end up in teaching and somehow
train them in among other things good
classroom management we cannot have
illusions as I think too many people do
writing on education that we can somehow
change the structure of incentives so
the entire Harvard and you know class
and Yale class in princeton class etc
it's going to gravitate towards teaching
it's not going to happen to be a
disaster it would be a disaster it would
be a disaster but there is an awful lot
of loose talk about that suggests such a
scenario thank you i want to thank the
panel thank Rick Abby and Tom and thank
all of you for coming Frederick has is
director of Education Policy Studies at
the American Enterprise Institute